[Music]
terry it is so nice to see you again
thanks for taking the time
good to see you too tim i tell you been
a long time it has and last time we were
in person on stage in los angeles now we
are remote still looking at each other
via video and
for those who can't see where i'm
sitting because they're listening to
audio i'm sitting in a studio with a
projection of the skyline of austin
behind me because i had
two location failures today this is my
third location
and you know made me think of something
i heard once when i did very little
television which was
or it was more of a joke and the joke
was
why does thunder come after lightning
and then the answer was because even god
waits for sound and i was
so i was hoping
if you could maybe just give people a
little bit of connective tissue
related to your professional life
because
people see the red carpet events they
see the tv shows and they they might
assume that it's just like all
highlights all day long and i i was just
wondering if you could maybe add a
little bit of color
to
what a day in the life
actually looks like because there's so
much behind the scenes
it's seasonal for me you know one thing
i learned um
is especially now it's not as
you know entertainment has changed
significantly just in the last five
years especially after the pandemic
of the last two years
and you know streaming has kind of taken
over
you know i had a much more structured
life before you know you do a sitcom and
you you kind of you know you wake up at
four in the morning get the workout in
go to the the set do your whole thing i
usually i i mean my workout is two hours
so no matter what my call time is i'm up
at least three hours before my call time
so that i can get all my you know my
workout in my showering all that stuff
and then i go right into a usual day but
and that's a 12
kind of sitcom day you know when i was
doing brooklyn nine-nine for eight
straight years
that was my my go-to and and
you know
that's kind of how a day went but
now i was streaming
and the way everything is going
people have now started to do
limited series and
i'm not on brooklyn anymore but i am
doing you know
i did
a stint on a tv series for amc called
tales of the walking dead which is going
to be really cool
but it was all in atlanta and and we
shot 15 hours and it was like shooting a
movie in 10 days you know what i mean
and that's kind of how everything goes
it's always like hurry up shoot it all
and then
now you're down for two weeks three
weeks finding out what your next thing
is
but this is the thing i never lose my
own structure you know what i mean i
you know wherever i'm at i have my the
first thing i find is where i'm gonna
work out
what and then also what i'm gonna eat
and also my timing of my eating i still
do intermittent fasting i'm going
i'm in the beginning of 12 years now
straight of intermittent fasting and
doing my eight hour window
of from two to ten and then it changes
by
when i go
to
you know whatever time zone i'm in
and now it's funny because a lot of
times i find
i can go one meal a day i actually enjoy
skipping that two o'clock
and then maybe by three or four having a
charcuterie or something like that with
some you know real satiating cheese and
some you know meat
and that's it and then i have a dinner
and then i'm done that's kind of the way
i've been doing it lately but the
industry changing so much and so much is
also on social media
you know it's now
they expect
every production expects to take all
your followers with them
you know so you're like doing two jobs
at the same time and this is where
i had to really really
kind of push back a little bit because
too much phone time is just not good for
you
yeah like i never bring my phone when
i'm working i leave my phone in the
trailer
i find that if you have you know if i
lose my focus i could lose my
career and the lack of focus
that comes from
always checking out email always
checking a post and looking at what
people are commenting on and this kind
of stuff man it it slowly but surely
changes you and i
i saw it happening and my performances
you know and i only did it for a small
time because i immediately started to
see a decline in my performances
it didn't look like i was there i didn't
feel present
i was somewhere else while i was saying
the lines and i said man
this is gonna hurt me
so i learned to just kind of leave all
and create a seasonal kind of thing with
my social media just kind of like
and what was crazy and what i've i
figured out i didn't lose any followers
in fact i would gain something you know
people are like where you been you know
i'm going oh my god cause you get this
feeling or you got to feed the beast
you know what i mean like if you don't
if you don't keep the pipeline running
all of a sudden you're just going to run
dry but
i i found it wasn't true um i found that
when it was when i'm doing america's got
talent and it's time to promote and time
to get your social media back up and
running it's like people never left yeah
and i was like man that was a really
good thing to find out you know what i'm
saying good to test early and learn that
you can do it yeah and again i try to go
to bed as early as i can like if i can
get to bed literally at 8 30
i'm gone
because i just enjoy my mornings like
with my workout it's my piece man i put
my headphones on i'll listen to your
podcasts i listen to
some i read a lot of good books via
audiobook
while i'm working out that just give me
the insights and
the thing that i need and i i literally
i probably read a book a week at least
and sometimes two if it gets really
rolling if the book is the books are
short
but i find that it the reading just
really keeps me keeps me level
level-headed in a world of quick blurbs
and
and people who want to excite everyone
else and get everybody riled up
one thing i like to say is the media
likes to get everyone angry and keep
them there
because it's very profitable you know
but reading
calms all that down you know what i'm
saying it's kind of like a very
it's a very realistic way of looking at
life you know i mean it's like as a as
opposed to blowing through the day it's
like you're enjoying a sunset when you
read a book you know what i'm saying
that's the analogy that i
i have for that
and it gives me great perspective
sometimes i read books on people that i
wouldn't normally
you know listen to or understand or try
to understand and you get a deep
you get a new empathy for different
people you may not you may not even
agree
but i can definitely empathize with
points of view and where people are
coming from
and it gives nuance where there is
i mean the death of nuance has been
kind of what's happening lately
you know i mean
sharp contrast so i have i've probably
27 footnotes that i've made for
follow-up questions on what you just
said so let me let me jump into some of
them we'll start with the end first
are there any books
audiobooks uh anything that you've kind
of consumed long form that has
stuck out to you or that has been
memorable
in the last could be six to twelve
months two years it's been a while since
you and i saw each other it feels recent
on one hand but
quite a while ago
there is a book
i'm trying to it's and walter isaacson
is like my favorite biographer you know
this man he gets so in-depth he's great
it's like you're living a life with
these people as you read it you know
what i mean
and i believe what is the one
oh my god it's about
it's with jennifer dudena and
breaker i think the comments code
breaker oh my god
that
let me tell you man i i'm a big science
guy and for people who don't know this
is crispr related i mean there's a lot
to it but very crisper related
well she jennifer was this biologist who
basically helped develop crispr but what
happened while i was reading the book
it blew me away because i learned about
and it's the first time i heard it but
it was all about james watson
you know watson and quick his teammate
they basically
discovered the whole
the helix the structure of the double
helix the structure of the double helix
and the whole thing but
you know james watson
went public about how he felt that uh
the intelligence of blacks
were inferior to everyone else because
of their
genes
and you gotta understand as i'm reading
this book my if my heart just sunk into
my stomach
i was like wow this is the man who
is probably going to be
go down in annals of history as being
you know
this innovator this this person that
really solves so many problems but here
he is creating a new one right at the
same time
it hit me really really hard because
this is another thing there was a level
of success you get to
that
it
actually can harm you
one example is even when i watch the
last dance the michael jordan
documentary and
and michael jordan is one of the
greatest athletes of all time
but was he happy yeah when you look at
the whole doc you go my god like
here's a man who's like i don't know if
we could really say
that he was actually fulfilled in any of
this
in fact
you know a lot of teammates a lot of
people were like he was one of the
people that you really didn't want to be
around you know what i mean and this is
the quandary this is not a judgment on
michael jordan but it's like
myself included
you know i was the guy who had what
everyone would say
was everything and and was great but i
had all these other things wrong
at the same time
and
here i was i was successful i was
popular and everybody liked me and the
whole thing but you know my wife was
ready to leave
she's like i can't put up with it
anymore and um
that reminded me a little bit of james
watson's conundrum you know what i mean
it was like
here he is one of the smartest men on
earth and he's got this thing so wrong
but see this is how we think even as men
we think whoever runs the business is
the guy with the biggest bench press
and you're like but that makes no sense
like yo but i have the biggest bench
press so i
i get to say what goes on in this
business but that doesn't mean you know
anything about inventory or you know but
it's it's such a wild take where you're
like
you're misrepresenting here
and for me
i look at those things
and these things in in hollywood in
science
in politics
in almost every genre
of of what you would call life and i
said man
that's
that's the mistake we could always make
and we can never forget that
and we have to humble ourselves we have
to
really really understand that we're all
just beginning even even when you've
succeeded when you've got this thing
you've got you're you're still starting
at
day one
every day
and is the mistake i think just assuming
that you know more than you know or that
you are
you have more certainty in more places
than you actually do is that the
the the crux of the issue or is there
would you describe it a different way
you know what i would describe the
mistake is
the mistake to me is self-righteousness
that's the mistake the mistake is you
have deemed yourself
self-righteous and when you are
self-righteous
you can now
do the most heinous
inhuman things to other people because
you feel right
because you you know in your heart
you're right and but for thousands of
years
and this is the thing where it is it's
so crazy because now we can we can mix
everything up
because people have i think there's a
lot of conflating going on even with
racism
people say well that's racist well
actually a lot of it is self-righteous
you know what i mean and if you define a
problem correctly you can actually deal
with the problem correctly and so but
and this is the thing about
self-righteousness is that you can be
black and self-righteous
you can be gay and self-righteous you
can be
you know white self-righteous you could
be a policeman and self-righteous you
could be all kinds of things it doesn't
matter you can be poor and
self-righteous
but we have these things especially in
hollywood where it's like you're poor
now you got the upper hand you know more
and you're the downtrodden and you're
this and that is kind of like what i
call victimology where it's like you've
created a hero out of anyone who's been
who's been abused or
or hurt but the issue is is also
there's two ways to be self-righteous
you can be
you know you can have like the divine
right of kings you can be like i was
born this way
or you can say i've suffered more than
anybody else
so now
i get to say how everything goes
you see what i mean i do i think a lot
of people have never looked at the other
side
you know what i mean it's just like
someone who suffered a lot is
immediately given all this this play
but my thing is is that
but you still have to
respect other people you still have to
understand that you
are no better than the others it's and
the phrase i've used before
and will continue to use is that it's
really
how can you compare your suffering to
another person
you know what i mean it's kind of like
it's not the oppression olympics
it's just not
you know you can't we got rights we get
to be right
because we've suffered the most
yeah
and i always look at that
and have to examine it
even in the light of my own suffering
and my own thing and let me tell you no
one has basically been a victim more
than terry crews
okay i had victimology down i was like
okay my my father was abusive my
you know i grew up i'm black i grew up
poor i grew up in the hood
i had every excuse in the book
you know what i mean and i felt
justified in my self-righteousness and i
use that i use that against my family
i use that to manipulate people
i use that
you know in order to
to gain things that i never earned
because i knew people would give me the
benefit of the doubt because of my
background
i knew i could use that but
in the end
when all is said and done i it did not
leave me fulfilled because i knew these
things
didn't play like the problem with with
victimology is all those excuses
they work
for a minute like but they they expire
very quickly you know i mean like i like
to call it an expired credit card
you know it's kind of like
your excuses they have a valid date but
inspires like really fast and then you
cut you try to use it the next day and
you get declined
you know what i mean and it's kind of
like yeah every
excuse you ever wanted to to use
there's a time when it doesn't work
anymore
i would love to hear more about your
your personal experience so you had as
you mentioned victimology down
and then at some point
you reflected back on that and
with self-awareness and then changed
behavior or your perspectives how you
approached things
were there any particular triggers was
there a particular day could you sort of
tell a story
or give us an example of something that
catalyze that change because for a lot
of people if they have any perspective
they may not change that they may not
actually have
a trigger to
turn it inward and take a look at that
so could you describe what happened
well you know in our house we call it
d-day
it was the day everything changed and
you know i've made a i've gone public a
lot about
my pornography addiction
and then there's a lot of people who who
say you could never really be addicted
to pornography or whatever and it's
always been said that but
all i knew is i couldn't stop
that's all i knew
for me it was a numbing device it was
something that i went to when i was sad
when i was happy
and i always went back to it and it left
me unfulfilled and i had to get
to get more
just to get
a feeling of fulfillment but then i
would be left empty again so
it just it was a cycle i couldn't stop
but it was also a secret that i held
from my family and my wife and the whole
thing and
my wife finally confronted me on it
and let me tell you what was what was so
wild
and and really really strange
is that i was the question i was asking
was why doesn't she believe me
but the question i should have been
asking was why did i lie
you know i mean like think about that
there's two same it's all in the context
is the same
and i'm sitting here lying and wondering
why she won't believe me
that's all out focused it was all her it
was the responsibility it was on her in
order to
make me right like you should believe me
because i'm telling you this but i was
lying
i was lying i don't i don't do it with
this no i got no problem i don't do any
of this and then
and why didn't she believe me
but once it
switched into why am i lying
all of a sudden it went inward
all of a sudden i had to ask myself
the questions i had been avoiding
for years and years and years
and it was like hey man you have an
issue
why aren't you doing something about it
and
and like i said and i would pull out
that card of excuses and
this and i would say well you know i'm a
man and you know man we need to we i
have a high sex drive and this kind of
stuff and i'll pull out that card and
then my wife declined it
that credit card was done it was expired
and she was out
and you know what tim
what's so crazy is that i was like fine
bye
leave
you know i'm terry crews i can get any
woman i want in fact i will and you know
what this is a normal thing in hollywood
divorce is is pretty normal and it's not
a big deal in fact my career won't
suffer
and
nobody cares if i lose my family
hollywood certainly doesn't
and it's you and then i listened to
myself talking like that
and i went who were you
like i didn't like that guy
and i started to have internal
conversations with myself and i was like
man
this is not
who you say you are
and i realized i was two different
people
and
when you have a double life when you you
and when i say a double life what i mean
is
i was more concerned with the image
i was more concerned with the image of
terry crews
rather than who terry crews really was
and that and it was two different people
and
once i started to
try to put them together
my world crumbled
everything that i knew everything that i
i was around everything that
i thought i stood for
i thought i was like yeah you know women
are equal in the whole thing but
nothing in my behavior
would would do that or even said that
and in fact i thought i was more
valuable than all the women in my life
simply because i was a man
simply because of the culture i was in i
grew up in black culture and hip-hop
culture
in sports culture
and there was a lot of misogyny it was a
lot of you're the man dawg hey man you
better get your girl in line
you know that kind of these kind of
words these kind of and it wasn't looked
at it was looked at as like yo man you
know you control your wife
or your girl
you actually owned her
i remember
in the nfl going to the strip club
and we'd be
in the club and with all the guys and
the whole thing and the girls be up on
stage and one of them would come down
and actually want to talk to the players
and i would look at
her like okay you know she start talking
you know i gotta get i gotta do this for
my kids and then and you're like stop
stop stop stop stop
you're like you're ruining
the experience
because you're becoming a human being
right before my eyes
i like you to be a picture i want you to
be a doll a
a mannequin
i mean
tim
once you start i i mean once you open
that can of worms
it's literally like a domino effect like
everything
started to fall on itself
and i said i i went through a huge huge
just
and then
i gotta say this because
in my culture
when i grew up
you know therapy was looked at as
ridiculous and
because they
i where i grew up it was like you can't
cure crazy that was the term
it was like if you're crazy you can't
cure it
i my father being an alcoholic he went
to a psychologist one time
and uh and i remember i was probably
around 12 13 years old and i'm like wow
i think you know my dad's finally gonna
get some help and the whole thing and uh
dude it was crazy because uh
like a week later the psychologist
killed himself it was on the front page
of the newspaper my god
and i went
that don't work you know my whole
mindset was like huh
like did my father kill him like you
know did he did he say something that
made this guy jump off a bridge and he
got literally jumped off a bridge
and i was like what that doesn't work
and so i had in my mind
that all this therapy stuff is mumble
jumbo
you know
and so there was a there was a block
there was a resistance to that
and i i finally saw a counselor who said
you need to go
to this place and get some therapy and i
was like oh no you know
and i remember
and my wife said look you know what if
you don't do this like
there's no hope of us ever coming back
together because we had split up at that
time
and so i went and i said all right i'll
give it a shot and i'm sitting there in
this room with these people and harry
may i interject for one second oh yeah
go ahead
one question so did did you guys
sort of split at that point or things on
ice because of how you handled the
situation
d-day in that conversation or was it the
subject
matter like the addiction itself and
other things
i guess i'm asking was it what you did
or was it how you handled
what you did or something else
it was what i did because what happened
was i confessed
to
a
infidelity that happened 10 years
earlier
as a result of this addiction because
you know i i went to a massage parlor
and got a hand job and
i vowed i would never ever tell anybody
you know it was one of them things but i
was it was at the beginning of my career
i was i was in vancouver i was by myself
i thought i would never be there i
thought i'd never do something like that
but you know it was wild because i found
myself in those circumstances and i did
it but i thought i would never tell i
was like i'm taking this secret to the
grave man this is never ever coming out
but my wife
constantly she was like no you did
something she said you're something
you're not telling me
and she knew and again like i said i was
lying
the whole time you know and
she could feel that you know i mean you
can feel when your significant other is
not telling you the truth and it was
just there was something she didn't know
and when i told her
i remember just
it came out and i remember she's going
that's it like
wow who am i living with like she had no
idea
and that was the thing because i was i
had
put an image in front of her and what
was so crazy is that she was married to
this image it wasn't fair it wasn't fair
to her
there's no honesty in the relationship
because you have to cover a lie with
another lie
and then it just keeps continuing to
grow i mean we were we were getting
farther and farther apart
is what was happening and she was she
knew it she felt it
and
that was the d-day moment and she said
i'm out
she's like that's it
you can't come home
and if you have to show me that you want
this that you want actually want to do
something and i like i said in the
beginning i was like i'm fine
and then i realized i was like you know
what because the whole thing was
it was about her
and it's little bitty questions it was
just like man
you know maybe it's me
and the real realization that hit me
that it was me
that it was
and i i have to say this going into
therapy
all the
the great thing about therapy and
especially with addiction therapy was
just the 12 steps
you know the 12 steps
they work for every sort of addiction be
it drugs alcohol sex
all these things and it starts with like
serenity prayer which has
helped me to accept the things
that i can't change and the courage to
change the things i can
and the wisdom to know the difference
okay
but you have to understand men
especially in my world
you live life as if you're in a revenge
movie
i'm laughing because i i i'm a lot
smaller than you are but i understand
you don't want me i get it i get it hey
movies like that man like payback and
death wish and oh wrath of man i mean
this is a long list yeah oh wrath of man
taking
this thing where you get on the phone
and you tell the guy i'm gonna hunt you
down
i'm gonna take you and your crew out one
by one
and you're gonna die slow you know it's
like man on fire also a good one
and you make them pay
for everything you make them pay for
everything they ever did to you
that's the male fantasy it's better than
sex
you know what i mean like tim it's like
oh my god you can literally sit in the
theater like man
oh that feels good
but this is the problem tim this is the
problem man i found out and this is so
crazy you can either have success
or revenge
but you can't have both
it blew my mind
and
when you're talking about getting
revenge
this is why i even alluded to the the 12
steps was because
revenge is trying to control things you
can't control
you know what i mean it's literally like
you've lost it
and now you just gotta even the score
you know
most of us are all about settling scores
you know
but
the thing is the score is never really
settled
things just get worse things tend to
fall apart i bring up incidents where
the things where i i used violence
i was the kind of guy i even start my
book out where i talk about how i beat
this man up on the street man for
disrespecting my wife
and this was in pasadena this was around
oh i would say 2008 2009
and this guy
he basically talked disrespectfully to
my wife
and she was just like whatever but i put
this dude out i mean
literally put his head on the concrete
and the police came
and it was a big hullabaloo man and i
the only way
i got out of it was because there was a
guy in the crowd who was like no no no
you know
i saw the whole thing officer
this guy came up there and they were
bothering them too and the whole thing
so i got away with it
but it was way out of
it was way too big a reaction for what
was done
but that was me settling my scores
here's the revenge movie you know
and my wife pulled me to the side and we
went home and she said terry
she said you have to promise me
promise me
that you will never ever do anything
like that again
and i was like what i mean you need to
be protected she said wait a minute she
said i got this
but you
are going to lose everything
you have
you said you're going to get sued you're
going to get shot and injured or you may
be killed
by someone who you go up against on the
wrong day or a police officer
you know like you can't go around
and putting people on their head like
this
until i was just like
i was like no i don't i i i said i got
to this is this is my thing this is me
being a man this is what this is about
this is me being tough
and she said no terry she said you got
to promise me promise me
so okay
all right i promise i promise and i
don't even think i meant it
you know at the time
but
i made a promise to her that i was gonna
gonna take the the righteous path and be
less violent you know and not or
non-violent and try to
handle things in a non-violent way and
little did i know in the future it would
actually save my life
in so many ways so many ways and
and what i mean is is by
not choosing revenge because that's what
that is
is when you put somebody on it you know
the whole thing is a little bit like
you're playing chess
and you don't know the right right move
so you turn over the board
that was my answer for everything
you know what i mean like i'm stuck on a
move
instead of thinking my way out of it my
answer was just turn everything over
yeah that was my answer for everything
and it led me to a very very hollow
existence
so there i was in therapy trying to
figure my life out
and trying to control the things that i
couldn't control
because you can't control people
you can't control what people say to you
and a lot has been said about even
my friend chris rock and my friend will
smith what just happened
at the academy awards right and i there
was a time when i was will smith
but what saved me
was when i was the time i was chris roth
and it didn't descend into chaos
i decided to what you would call take an
l for one day
but actually win the whole war
the other thing in therapy i discovered
is when you can
have the courage to change the things
you can
and let me tell you this
there was some because of victimology i
had given up control on probably every
aspect of my life
i it was
it was always up to somebody else
even where where i worked what i did it
was always someone else's decision
and then i found out i had a lot more
power than i realized i was like if i
just work on me
if i stop pointing at everyone else
and i just put 100 percent
into improving myself
all of a sudden things started to change
tim
i have to tell you man
that first year was really really hard
coming out of therapy and i mean i was
there in and out for a while we would do
it by phone we would go back in it was a
place called psychological counseling
services in phoenix and
and they had dealt with a lot of people
who had a guy who had really lost
everything because of these kind of
addictions
and it was really it was wild because i
thought can i change
i was getting triggered every five
minutes it's like
i don't know but what was happening is
as i continued to work on myself i began
to change
i changed
i slowly but surely
started to see things
the way i needed to see them you know
and what's so crazy about belief
is when you believe you're different
you slowly start to become different
you have to believe it first you know
what i mean terry would you mind giving
an example it would be very helpful
because i
i think from the outside looking in
people see this incredible physical
specimen
certainly in all my interactions with
you and your descriptions and stories
and tribe of mentors you've done a lot
of self
development and you've
worked on yourself a lot could you give
an example from that chapter
during or after therapy of something
that you worked on or a belief
that you
gave attention to
i could tell you a distinct example that
let me know i was different
we were on vacation and it was wait and
it's so innocuous and small and tiny
but it was so powerful
we were on vacation and
my son
was 16 now but he was probably four
years old
and i have five total kids you know four
daughters and my son
and we were out to dinner
and
he spilled his water all over the table
and
it was all over me it was all over
everybody and i just said hey man
i said that's okay we'll get a towel
and i said hey man we people make
mistakes it's okay
you know and i started dabbing up the
water and the whole thing now that
sounds like nothing
the whole table was looking at me like
this
i mean they just were froze like eyes
bugged out like
what is
this
you have to understand him
the way i was was like what is wrong
with you what i mean you didn't you see
the water right there yeah you now you
what you're gonna you know you you got
me wet you got this way you look you
you're costing it i i paid for this
dinner you guys can't stay stay still
you guys are not paying attention i mean
i would have went off
tim i can't count
the
family events
and the things that we went to do
that i ruined
now you have to also have to understand
that these things were happening also
because
with my addiction comes guilt
you know you're lying you know i mean
you know what you're doing
so
you
take it out on everyone else
i would snap at the end of at the drop
of a hat
and
it was because i was angry with me
because i couldn't control myself
so i would go off on everyone else this
this common like uh you know where your
your projection that's the term and i
was projecting my own guilt onto
everyone else
and i was that guy i have to say i still
i have adult children right now that i
still apologize profusely
for how they grew up the terry crews
that i was back then
was
he was
my way or the highway it was vicious
now this is the thing tim
and again i was mr self-help still and
and the whole thing is i never
i never hit my wife because i was like
my mom went through that so my idea of
was i was comparing myself
to what i saw and i was like i'm way
better than that
you know what i grew up in
it was like man people women were
getting smacked like with impunity and
it was expected that you were to beat
your wife
it was expected that you owned your kids
and you beat them within an inch of
their lives you know what i mean and so
i'm like i'm better than that look at it
i mean you guys are
living a good life
and you ought to be lucky you know what
i mean and but it was still cruel
it was cruel
it was
self-righteous yeah that
self-righteousness that i had
a mix in with the guilt that i already
felt
it really kept my family in
this this kind of cage
in an attempt to control them in an
attempt to control
my family and control the way they
thought and control
everything control the fact that you
spilled the water
you know i mean
yeah and man my wife looked at me when
when i just dabbed that water up
and didn't lose the thing
let me tell you man i didn't even i
wouldn't have perceived it
she said oh my god
and she pulled me to the side she said
terry
you're different
man i'm
i'm sorry it's i mean just even
a mad going back to that moment i was
like what
she was like terry you're different
you changed you changed
and it hit me
that all and this is years later this is
years into the therapy you know years
into constantly working on myself
and my behavior started to change
and i'm gonna fast forward a little bit
to 2017
is when i think i believe what was crazy
we were still going through it last time
we talked but um
i talked about the time my agent
assaulted me
at a party in hollywood
and
the whole thing was i mean it was so
degrading
and so i mean i pushed him off i was
like what is your problem i don't know
what his problem was
i think he was on he was high or
whatever i don't know what he was doing
but
it was all i could say is this here this
guy
he's the head of the motion picture
department of william morris endeavor
my own agency
and
he grabs my crotch in the middle of this
party and i'm going get off me what the
hell are you doing
now my first instinct because what i've
done my whole life
is to put people on their head
and i could have killed this guy
i mean i don't i don't even think that
there's anybody
who could who would even doubt
my ability to murder this man you know
it's like that's not the question here
but i remembered my promise
and i remembered my therapy
and i remembered
the water
i
i remembered
that that was different
and i said
you know what this the whole
phrase responsibility is
is just that
the ability to respond
i can choose how i'm going to act
in this way
and i went against decades of
programming
and said
no
no
i grabbed my wife's hand
and we walked out
now tim i'm gonna tell you i got in the
car i was gonna drive the car right back
to the club i'm trying to like terminate
you know what i mean again the movie
never stopped the revenge movie was
still there too like i was going to turn
around and drive right through the front
door
and just start blazing on everybody i
was like that was in my head
but i kept driving
and i remember not even seeing where i
was going
and i ended up in the driveway
and i remember my wife's voice echoing
over and over she said i'm proud of you
terry
i'm proud of you terry
i'm proud of you
because she said she was there she saw
the whole thing
she said i'm so proud of you i'm so
proud of you and it kept me and it held
me
man and now when i say it saved my life
the question is is would anyone who
believed me
had i knocked this guy out
that's the question i like to give to
anybody
i could have said yeah he did this
whatever and and and
and everyone would have looked at me
like wait a minute he's the head of
william morris that makes no sense
why would he do that
and you knocked him out maybe because
you are angry about something there you
are super big
muscular angry black man
who probably got pissed off
probably was drinking too much
and i don't drink
at all but everyone would have had a
picture of what happened that night
that i would not have been able to
overcome
at all
and like i said i even asked the head of
william morris i asked
arya emanuel
i said man
if i'd have knocked him out would you
have any mercy on me
and he said no terry we wouldn't
and
we
wouldn't
like damn it
this is the world we live in
and think about this when when i look at
the jails that are full right now
of young black men old black men
how many were baited
how many were pulled
how many were tricked into reacting
in a way how many were
were baited into turning that chess
board over
and it's so easy
because again it's the revenge movie
you know it's so easy because that's
what you're supposed to do
tim let me tell you right now in our
community in the black community there
is an expectation that if anybody calls
you [ __ ]
you knock them out
that's the reaction i mean this was told
to me
many many times
and and it's told to each other like man
if you they're videos on tick tock
about when it happens you see it
somebody called somebody a [ __ ]
and all of a sudden you knocked the guy
out no matter what
but the thing is and thing that hit me
and it hit me hard was that
i would only really be offended
if i felt i was a [ __ ]
but there
there's no such thing as a [ __ ]
so
why would you offend me
see i had to examine all of these things
like it's like calling bill gates broke
he would look at you and laugh like
okay
you know what i mean
and so if anybody ever called me [ __ ]
i can look at you and go hmm
no that's not it
and i can count it to ignorance
instead of it being a bait and a switch
and a trigger
in order for someone to get me into a
position
that would make me vulnerable
and also let me do and let me tell you
tim
this stuff
is tough
this is what i call the book tough
because it's it's hard
to do it's very very hard
so i want to dive into i'm actually
going to pull up a couple of paragraphs
about the book because i've been looking
forward to this conversation for many
reasons and the title for folks just so
they get the idea tough my journey to
true power so i want to read
just an abbreviated two paragraphs and
then launch into a question about this
so
from brooklyn 99 terry crews the deeply
personal story of his lifelong obsession
with strength and how after looking for
it in all the wrong places he finally
found it now there are several
paragraphs but i'm gonna leave those for
now and come to the
the last that i have in this little
blurb which is with tough cruise journey
of transformation offers a model for
anyone who considered themselves a tough
guy in quotation marks but feels
unfulfilled anyone's struggling with
procrastination or self-sabotage and
anyone ready to achieve true
lasting self-mastery so
let me
combine that and i apologize for the
long question but it will have a
question mark at the end of it
a quotation that i love that i believe
you also love
which is from ralph waldo emerson which
is
god will not have his work made manifest
by cowards yes and the reason i bring
that up is that
my experience also just being
male
and priding myself on having certain
characteristics or developing certain
types of strength
is that you don't want to be perceived
as a coward you don't want to perceive
yourself as a coward
so
how do you think about the and i think
the reason many people many men let's
just say
respond hyper aggressively in different
situations is to prove to themselves and
others that they're strong and not weak
so
how do you
this might sound like a funny question
but
sort of demonstrate strength
think about strength so that you don't
have that self-perception maybe maybe
that's a bad question but i'd love to
just see
where that goes because if someone
i i feel like for for someone to have
the ability to walk away they need to
have supreme confidence
on some level in their own strength or
that maybe that self-perception so i'd
love to hear you
speak to any of that in any direction
that might make sense
listen i understand your question
because that was the conundrum that i
dealt with even when my wife challenged
me on this stuff i was like but what if
somebody does this and you know and
the thing is is that toughness in a
supremely hyper masculine world
is about how hard can you give a punch
but what i found is that there's a
there's a
toughness in a right kind of world
is how you take them
there's two ways like to be a great
boxer you have to learn how to take them
you know what i mean the greatest boxers
in the world took punches
that's the issue yeah if you have a
glass jaw
you know i mean you can have the hardest
swing
of all time i mean i i look at
you know
but all the fight fans out there when
you look at foreman ali
and all the punches he took
and yeah i would never recommend anybody
go through that you know
but what i say is how that right there
was is a sign
to me that there's there's another
toughness that's involved endurance
i guess that's the phrase
endurance
which is not a
you know super fast two-minute
three-minute event
it's
long it's long term it's it's how much
can you take
you know what i mean how long can you i
love love love victor franco
and
his story and i've probably read
everything that he's ever put out and
the endurance that this man
put up with in the nazi
concentration camps
as he watched all his
his
friends die his family died
his wife and
and he came out saying yes to life
i said man that's that's the kind of
endurance
that
transcends and i think that it's truly
truly
one of the things where that level of
toughness
is where i want to be
because this is another thing you know
the world really really determines
winners way too early
they just do i mean
and it's always celebrated i mean the
valedictorian of your high school you
know that's
but most of these people don't end up
winning
long term you know what i mean it's like
whoever's winning at a young age it's
like wait a minute
i think
we need to look at the people who over
time
have displayed
success and really displayed
just have seen the most of life and seen
all the lumps and been through all the
things and what have they been through
that's where you get your real examples
i am a results oriented person whereas
when i see how
most of the world celebrates just
instant wins
you know what i mean
i like to call it the sportification of
our culture
you know things have been sportified
and this is where it goes back to even
our last conversations when i say how
people have
how i feel that competition is the
opposite of creativity
yeah this is so key i highlighted that
when i reviewed our our first
conversation i'd love for you to just
elaborate on that i will i will because
i it's something that's that i've been
challenged on people like but you
without competition you'll never get
better and you've got to have
competition you've got to and i said no
you don't you do not have to compete
with
other human beings
now the thing is you don't need
competition but you do need resistance
two different things
this is the work the fact that you get
up is a resisting it's you're gonna face
resistance
with going outside the wind is fighting
you you know when you if you plant
something weeds are automatically grow
they grow up anything good is attacked
you have to build a house you have to
everything is so easy for entropy to
happen but everything that's worth
something has to be built has to be
redesigned it has to be created and it
has to you automatically have resistance
but competition however
i think
you know imagine if the world had
evolved through competition there would
only be
one set of people
it doesn't work that way the world
evolved through collaboration
that's how i feel society evolved that's
how humanity evolved it's all through
collaboration
but again that revenge movie that whole
thing that we live it's about
competition it's about putting me on top
and now i'm on top and i got to cancel
everybody else and and so and so you got
to go down
and i am the winner and you're the loser
and
this is it's a sportification it's like
i won i beat everybody i'm the best in
the world
today it's king of the hill
but someone's coming to kick you off
and when you live those rules it's kind
of like if you if you go
your whole life canceling everybody you
eventually have to cancel yourself
because you're not perfect you know i
mean it's like
one thing that gets me man hollywood
loves to point the fingers at everybody
and hollywood on the at the academy
awards it actually canceled itself
which blew my mind
the standing ovation after the assault
i was everyone was sitting there like at
home like what
you canceled yourself
this is crazy yeah and you realize wait
a minute
now when i go when i go into
collaboration
when you realize that the world is a
house
and this is the thing and the world this
is the way guys like to play where it's
like hey man i i'm on my side of the
house i got the kitchen the kitchen is
mine i can cook whatever i want and
they'll flaunt it like i got all this
kitchen and it's all mine but other
guy's like well check it out i'm on this
side of the house i have the bathroom i
can take a shower i'm clean i'm good
well tim eventually
the guy in the kitchen's got to use the
bathroom
and the guy with the bathrooms gotta use
the kitchen you see what i'm saying like
now this is the problem because if it's
a sport
who won
who won yeah
right today the guy with the bathroom
but tomorrow the guy with the kitchen
and it's endless
and when you do that what you're doing
to me it's like
you know
this is a phrase i love to use and there
was a lot being said i i said things
about
what was going on with black lives
matter what was going on with a lot of
our culture during this whole time
and i my issue was that any
movement that doesn't start
with reconciliation
i don't want any part of
we have to reconcile we have to
reconcile men to women
we have to reconcile black to white
we have to reconcile republican to
democrat
we have to we have to reconcile that's
the first rule because if we don't
what you're doing is postponing a war
that's all you're doing
it's postponing it
it's a matter of okay
you know we strike the day
and we'll have to wait and then we'll
get our get our bearings together and
we'll strike again later and then they
come get you and you come get them
but with reconciliation
there's an agreement
with reconciliation there's an
understanding
with reconciliation is peace wherever
you were reconciled there's going to be
peace
you know
and
i
knew and and i got in a lot of trouble
at the time
for talking about hey i
decide to unite with good people black
and white
no matter the race
no matter the color
no matter the creed no matter the
ideology
i said i am going to unify with good
people and
i was
i was really put through the ringer for
that
but i feel really good about it because
i made my stand in the middle
of a lot of name calling a lot of
of people who wanted to fight
and
and listen i understood the anger
i understood it i was that guy
you know what i mean i was like
but i realize if we if we just turn over
the chess board every time
we're not going to get anywhere you know
i mean it's like
these kind of things have to be
there's no winning until we reconcile
there's no sometimes you gotta stop
playing the game
you know what i mean and when i say a
game that's exactly what i'm talking
about you have to walk off the court
and say we're not playing today
now we're gonna we're gonna work
together
one thing that
has
always impressed me about you and our
interactions and looking back at your
history and certainly in our first
conversation we talked a lot about
your
art and your ability and
many many
sort of chapters of life spent with one
foot in the art world which we won't get
into right now but people can really
take a look at this very closely and
they should
and also
from from the
segwaying from
playing professional sports
then to say entertainment and then
folding in the design elements
you're very good at questioning the
rules of the game
and choosing new games to play and i
think it really
highlights a number of things one of
which is
your ability to choose creativity over
competition right you like terry crews
is a category of one and if you create a
category of one
it's kind of blue sky and you can create
the rules of the game that you want to
participate in as opposed to
constantly climbing hill after hill
depending on who offended you or upset
you that day to go through like the
vengeance marathon
which is a not just an exhausting way to
live but it's also a very incremental
way
to succeed in
in any given field so i i just wanted to
say that i
i spot that pattern over and over again
in you and i admire it a lot
thank you so much for that and i
that's what
just to
elaborate on your point
that's what bothered me so much about
what james watson
alluded to
because he
now
race was a competition
and i was like but you need each other
we all
we need everyone
you know and if you make a competition
out of it about this race is smarter
than the other do the genes and this
kind of things i was like man
what are you talking about like
think about the musical
greatness that black culture has brought
in i mean that's a whole nother kind of
intelligence that's there's several ways
to be intelligent you know what i'm
saying and i'll go
you know you can't do what thelonious
monk did you know what i mean you can't
redo that it's one of these things where
you look at john coltrane and you go my
god like
how do you even
you can't even
put math on that it's kind of like wow
how did you create that
it's another level of intelligence that
we don't understand
but if you create this game
that everybody has to play
and then you determine the winners and i
said man i it was a huge mistake
and like i said it hurt me so bad
because i love science
and i love this stuff and i see a lot of
scientific racism involved with even
when you're talking about coding and
with computers and
in that world where
there was i believe shockley i think his
his name was who
was really came up with some very racist
things about
uh just about
the ability to learn computers and
black people and this whole thing and i
just go man
these guys
it's that that self-righteousness you
can't but this is another thing and then
this is what i had to address
i've seen black people get the same way
about what they have
and they go we are
more gifted in this and we're more
gifted than that
and i said man all of that is the
biggest mistake you can ever make
because
that level of self-righteousness will
allow you to be extremely cruel
to anybody else
it's kind of like i don't know what to
say but it's
you can't feel wrong because you don't
think you're wrong
and you can't even hear what people are
saying
and it's so dangerous
and so insidious
that you have to call it out like a
cancer it's almost like a growth
that can grow on any movement
because most things start out with
people with great intentions
you gotta agree i mean most things
most churches most events most movements
most things and then all of a sudden
people are in guyana and
drinking flavor raid with jim jones and
it's like what happened
yeah
there was a moment when things twisted
and it's a tragedy
and i don't want to see that
i was in a christian cult in college it
was nuts
but you see how
just because you have great intentions
if they're not checked if you have if
they're not balanced if they're not
really if you don't really get that
self-righteousness out of there and
start at day one every day you're gonna
be on the wrong path and this is where i
am i'm constantly learning
constantly saying be teachable man
be
teachable
it's so wild because i'm gonna give you
a crazy crazy story
really funny
i was on i'm doing my first year of
america's got talent and i'm loving it
i'm doing my thing
and
i wear these beautiful suits and outfits
and the whole thing and i love this
whole thing you know i'm mr creative i'm
like oh my god i got this great shoes i
got this great thing
and we had this thing we had a suit that
we had a belt on the outside of it it
was really unique and kind of unique you
know really high fashion well i decided
i'm gonna go on the show i'm gonna do
this and the nbc rep is like uh
terry could you just take the belt off
i was like
oh really like
you you you talking to me
i was like hey man do you know who i am
you know it was like i am your show i am
the host of this show i
can wear whatever the hell i want to
wear tim it was like that i switched
into this like
what how dare you talk to me like that
and dude
it was it was wild because i was with my
representatives and the people and they
were like you don't have to change it
you don't have to change whatever you
want yeah yeah man you don't have to do
that just go out there anyway go out
just do what you want
and all of a sudden it hit me tim
they said hey man
dude you're driving their car
nbc is their truck that's their car
but if they don't want the rims to spin
take the damn rims off man like
it's like dude why are you flipping on a
belt
it was like man humble yourself
relax
because dude
these are the boss i said it's their
show
it's not my show
and i said oh my god it was i was that
close
to pulling this arrogant move where i
was just gonna go do whatever i wanted
anyway
and it probably would have put
everything that i my whole future in
jeopardy
and i took the belt off
the show went great
the nbc rep was like thank you terry
because a lot of times
bosses just want to be heard
and and the show was awesome
and i realized how close i came
of one arrogant move to losing probably
one of the best jobs i ever had because
it starts there
it's not one big giant move it's always
one little thing and then it grows and
grows and grows
and i said man you gotta start at day
one every day
terry
so it's it's hard hard lessons man like
i said this is tough it's tough stuff
that's tough hence the title of the book
you know it made me think also
about the
example the metaphor you used earlier of
walking outside and the wind is fighting
you right like maybe that's just the
wind like that encounters just the wind
it's not someone attacking you or
insulting your
manhood or
it's just the wind in some cases right
sir
i've taken a lot of notes in this
conversation for myself i'm i'm really
looking forward to the book
and
i also feel like
this balance that that you've described
you know i think especially for
and not exclusively for but i think
often for a lot of the men listening
will be
one that comes up a lot it's like how do
you
find a place for
male strength
if you feel like that has sort of been
removed from society
how do you
develop not just the self-perception but
the capability of being strong
having that endurance that resilience
sort of defining strength in a way that
isn't
abusive and corrosive
and
i also wanted to just mention
because you brought up his name
felonious monk and one of
my favorite quotes is actually from
felonious monk and i wanted to bring it
up because i think you
exemplify it by constantly revisiting
who you are starting at day one asking
yourself not just who is terry crews but
like who does terry crews want to be and
the quote is a genius is the one most
like himself i just think there is
there's so much depth in that quote
that's the loneliest monk genius is the
one most
like himself of course that could apply
to herself
but
every day is day one like you said
that's right that's right i love it
i know we're coming up on time terry
the new book
people can find it wherever books are
sold tough subtitle my journey to true
power i highly recommend people check it
out people can find you on social media
at terry crews on twitter instagram and
then on facebook reel terry crews is
there anything else that uh you'd like
to
say any other comments questions
complaints that you'd like to
add before we wrap up
man first of all i just always always
enjoy talking to you tim this let me
tell you this 90 minutes went like
true i i it went so fast i can't even
wait quickly it went quickly but i just
want to thank you for letting me share
my heart man
what's wild is i tend to get
misunderstood sometimes
and
a lot of that is because of the ability
to take things out of context
and i thank you for
letting me talk and and so that it's in
context so you can see
where it's coming from and where it
ended you know yeah for sure
when i see the future
of
what this world is
i'm very hopeful
i am an eternal optimist
and a lot has been said about getting
things wrong and everybody making
mistakes
and this kind of thing but my thing is
these errors
can push you into better things
one thing i like a quote that i heard
that i love that got me through the
pandemic is that sometimes your greatest
hopes are destroyed to prepare you for
something better
and when you see your hope being dashed
people get disheartened
but i like to see it sometimes as you're
being prepared
for something better
for what is next
and i truly truly think
that we can have that better
and i really do
and and i'm not a cynical this is
another thing you know a lot of a lot of
comedians tend to get a cynicism in this
whole kind of thing and i've always
resisted that
i'm at war with cynicism
i've decided to be
positive and be hopeful
and believe the best
about every human being
and count a lot of this as
a lot of negativity as ignorance and
until people can figure it out
i'm here for you until i figure cause i
don't haven't even figured it out you
see what i mean so we're all on this
journey
because i can tell you 20 years ago oh
man i was i was among the ignorant you
know like oh
i could easily be
making excuses and the whole thing and
that's why i have so much empathy for
everyone out there
everyone anywhere because it's just a
matter of time so
thank you for letting me share my heart
thank you terry and
i i want to say
to you everybody listening there are
many forces in the world that want you
to be apathetic and i invite you to also
be at war within
yourself against cynicism because it is
crippling
and
what a great way to phrase it terry
thank you so much again everyone check
out tough my journey to true power you
can find links to everything we
discussed in the show notes at tim dot
blog forward slash
podcast and until next time be a little
bit
kinder than you think is necessary
both to others and to yourself and
thanks for listening
you